[Music]
all right good afternoon everyone thank
you for joining deep learning in our
with Google cloud in our studio my name
is Mikhail shrestha I'm a machine
learning specialist within Google clouds
customer engineering team and I'm really
excited to also have Andre here with me
he's a solutions engineer at our studio
the co-author of the book R for dummies
and a very very avid contributor to the
Stack Overflow community I think I saw
you were in the top 400 there the top
point one percent and Andre is also a
gentle reminder that I have work to do
to fill the white space to the right of
my picture for next time so stretch
goals for 2020 - maybe author a book
store agenda today is really a little
bit around the motivation around this
session we're gonna talk about the rml
ecosystem with Google cloud in our
studio Andre is gonna walk you through
the deep learning steps in our and
sprinkle three demos and then we're
really gonna close close with a summary
so why are we here today I started using
our in 2005 as an Operations research
student at that time outside of academia
our was found in small pockets within
the industry I then spent seven years in
data science and analytics consulting
with a big four firm and I slowly saw
are being evaluated and slowly adopted
across data science teams now in 2018 as
a customer engineer here at Google and
talking to a lot of IT and data science
organizations we're slowly seeing are in
every single conversation we talk about
machine learning that's my personal
story but the data backs it up when we
talk about various indices rankings that
you stackoverflow github Google Trends
or various search search engines our
usage continues to rise Kaggle which
which join the Google family last year
also released a survey in 2017 where are
still the top tool of choice for a
business analyst data analysts and
statisticians why is this so important
you'll hear the theme around
democratizing ml and AI across today's
today's sessions as well as the
conference and this is important because
really there's only a few million data
scientists and ml practitioners in the
world today there's definitely a skill
skill shortage but when we talk about
developers business analysts data
analysts statisticians we can really
expand that number to the tens of
millions we have a lot of ways around
democratizing this during FIFA's keynote
yesterday you saw cloud auto ml a way to
build natural language vision and
translation machine learning models
without coding we had the Kaggle
community which allows access to various
public data sets best practices now for
the coders tensorflow is in the center
of this ecosystem we've slowly expanded
this ecosystem to include tensorflow for
mobile tensorflow for javascript to run
in browsers and today we're very excited
to bring tensorflow for our from our
studio to this ecosystem now everyone in
the room here can I get a show of hands
how many have used our before how many
of you are our users great so we have we
have a packed house here so why should
you here why should you care about deep
learning a quick primer there's a lot of
sessions or out deep learning and
tensorflow here
we're gonna go through some of the
suggestions sessions that are still
available later today and tomorrow but
deep learning is another machine
learning technique alongside regression
classification and clustering the real
nuance behind this is that we have a lot
of a lot of hidden layers within
artificial neural networks that allow
you to model a lot more complexity why
is this fundamentally different from
traditional ml techniques the more data
you give it the better it gets other
techniques tend to have a plateau but
with deep learning the more data you
collect the more examples you feed it we
really are seeing breakthroughs and
accuracy and really two applications you
want to think about number one is new
domains for traditional our usage
breaking into what we call perception
services vision natural language speech
when we talk about the ability to
diagnose diseases within medical imagery
when we talk about identifying product
quality defects on manufacturing lines
being able to classify product reviews
automatically there's a there's a whole
new use cases for that but second let's
not forget about our traditional
structured use cases we really believe
deep learning has a place for specific
niches around sequential data to
actually drive more value and squeeze
out the actual accuracy and
also for very heavy feature engineering
also known as variable enrichment deep
learning can really help to speed up
that as well
now if you're convinced about deep
learning
why tensorflow just a couple of quick
bullets on it it is a numerical
computation library allows you to run
operations in parallel this really
allows you to distribute large machine
learning training jobs across machines
as our users we're usually restrained to
the RAM of a machine with tensor flows
framework we really are able to now
leverage big data in the machine
learning space and then finally
tensorflow is a growing community and an
ecosystem where we're open sourcing not
just algorithms but actual reference
architectures that you can start using
immediately without architecting these
neural networks from scratch and then
the third and final piece is why Google
Cloud we want you to focus on your are
code we don't want you to worry about
spinning up infrastructure we don't want
you to maintain these clusters we really
want you to focus on the code deploy it
into managed services whether that means
you're trying to store millions of
images audio files machine logs whether
you're trying to query petabytes of data
really want you to use Google Cloud
Storage at Google bigquery that you've
heard about in other sessions as well
and then the last piece which is really
what I'm really close to is really
speeding up the time to operationalize
models from traditional data science
workload workflow with our really treats
are as a data science experimentation
place and then you need to really work
with IT to production-wise it we'll go
through some examples where we're able
to deploy those models directly for
consumers and developers to consume your
models in API form and finally I think
the most really the most important
pieces we're excited to bring the art
community to the deep learning world
here's a great quote from JJ oler who's
the CEO of our studio and it's really
the great strong foundational background
in statistics and applied mathematics
that the art community can bring and
educate the machine learning community I
had a couple of great conversations with
Andre over the last two days I wanted to
see if you could add a couple of
thoughts around this this theme
thanks Michael so yes I was
I think the heritage of tensorflow is
traditionally been through computer
science and the fact that we have built
a full port of attentive flow into our
and you can use the full attentive flow
library in our that makes it accessible
to people who have traditionally been
probably statisticians first rather than
computer scientists and physicians care
more about less about blackbox models
and more about inference and standard
errors and what is the uncertainty I
have here so I think there was a lot of
scope for statisticians to contribute to
this field a lot of green feel that we
can contribute to making this deep
learning experience much more much more
meaningful for statistics end consumers
great thanks I agree let's let's dive
right in into the ml ecosystem with
Google cloud in our studio first a very
bird's-eye view the very first top layer
are our favorite IDE our studio really
being able to use that in a internet
browser such as Chrome the middle layer
the our session the interface this can
be on your local machine this could be
on a virtual machine it could be on a
cluster but really this is where all
your our libraries were managed and now
when we talk about extending your art
toolkit again for cloud computing and
deep learning first data we talked about
bigquery our data warehousing analytics
analytic solution that can that can
process petabytes of data in seconds and
minutes cloud storage working with
hundreds of millions of images and log
files the modeling layer tensorflow and
caris and then really on that last theme
around minimizing time to time tamarcus
scalability how can I train a model very
quickly as a managed service on-demand
and then deploy as an API that's really
where a cloud machine learning engine
fits into the picture I'm gonna drill
into this a little bit but these are
just the the moving parts so let's talk
about the overall reference architecture
we're starting with your development
environment currently our studio server
Pro is actually available as a one-click
deployment on Google cloud platforms new
marketplace so this really installs
image
spins up a machine that has all the pre
installations and libraries required
this is where you installed tensorflow
and caris we also are seeing a
convergence of DevOps and and data
science we really want to manage code
effectively a lot of you in the audience
probably use github or git lab for a lot
of your code we really have the ability
to quickly set up a private get using
Google Cloud source repositories to
manage that code again we talked about
being able to access data this really
minimizes the dependency on your
environment you can spin up your art
environment and a in a laptop in a very
light Chromebook and now you can just
you can push all the hard heavy lifting
to these manage services on demand as
needed and not have to really worry
about procuring all this hardware and
new servers now we get is the training
piece training small sandbox models or
experimental models on your local aspyn
to make sure your code is working but
you really want to derive the most
insight and value from deep learning I
mentioned we need more and more data in
the vision space natural language space
and this is where training on cloud
machine learning engine basically
uploads all the required our packages
and tensorflow into a cluster of
machines and runs that for you we also
have deployment and serving Google cloud
machine learning learning engine also
has an API service for you to register
your model in a central repository for
your entire organization now whether it
be applications developers analysts to
use that model as a simple REST API call
our studio also has a great new product
our studio connect to really manage that
entire ecosystem of models and then
finally how do we consume that and this
is a great piece this box is
specifically a little bit on the gray
within Google Cloud it could be
on-premise you might have applications
with App Engine you might be using our
shiny which is a great visualization
front-end tool from our studio as well
or mobile devices
these this opens up all these models
that you've built in our for consumption
across across the company across your
consumer products internal processes at
this point I'm going to hand it hand it
over to Andre to talk about what the our
live
there are to make this possible that was
a great introduction about why you would
want to use tensor flow as an eye user
if you want to do that you should know
about a couple of packages that are
available on cron which are lists here
the first one is well bottom left they
start with tensor flow that's the most
famous one and the tensor flow package
on crime is actually a full wrapper
around everything that's in the Python
base layer in tensor flow everything you
can do in Python with tensorflow you can
do in are 100% coverage but tensorflow
itself is quite a low-level programming
environment you basically have to write
some mathematical equations to make use
of that right so I see some people
nodding their heads the much more
sensible thing to do as a practitioner
is to use Kerris which is a higher level
wrapper library around sensor flow now
the Charis package also available on
krong again is a hundred percent
coverage of the chemists library and
python ok and everything you can do in
care us on Python you can do nor do you
fit and that's the that's the one I
would recommend you using most of your
day-to-day data science exploratory work
TF estimators is a package that is much
more targeted at a use case where you
have large amounts of data you have
simple models and you want to take that
into production very quickly that's
basically the type of thing you use as a
computer scientist and you want to embed
some machine learning into a physical
device it's unlikely as an hour user you
will touch TFS tomatoes very much but
then we also have supporting tools to
make it possible to get your data into
the required formats TF datasets gives
you scaleable input pipelines TF runs I
will talk about a little bit more detail
it gives you a great way of running your
tensor flow experiments in a systematic
way and TF deploy enables you to publish
your train model onto either a studio
connect
or into the Google cloud email service
and caramel is a porch or a great way of
accessing the cloud email of services on
Google and I will actually demonstrate
some of that hopefully live all right so
why would you do this so if you if you
shorten ideas about why you should care
about this we have some great examples
on our gallery at our studio the
classical examples of tensorflow for
complex perceptual problems as Mihai all
said earlier so image classification
research in cancer - therapy color code
for for detection machine translation
these types of complex perceptual
problems and typically people will tell
you that you need very large amounts of
data for that to be sensible
I will actually demonstrate much more of
a toy example something that fits on my
laptop very very easily and just to
illustrate the point that it you don't
need to have a million images for
tensorflow to make sense you can
actually use tensorflow on traditional
machine learning problems I'm not saying
that tensorflow is going to outperform
XG boosts or if you have structured data
that's probably not going to be the case
but it has a place in in these mixed
environments okay so it's still briefly
about the steps in building a Karass
model and unsurprisingly the these steps
are exactly the same steps you would you
would take for pretty much every machine
learning a problem anyway maybe the
compilation step is a bit different I'll
show some code but let here's the
highlight first of all you define your
model typically that'll be a sequential
model where your your layers follow
sequentially one on the other that is
the majority of examples you'll see are
layers that just sequentially follow on
but there's also a
a functional model that allows you to
combine different neural networks if you
have more complicated problems and a
Karass allows you to have multi-gpu so
you can run that your code not just not
just a single machine but also on
classes of GPU very easily ok once
you've set up the model then there's a
very simple step of compilation that
compiles the code via Python interview
then the native C++ and for that step
you'll define your optimized that you
lost function and the metrics you want
to measure typically it'll be your
validation I could receive something
similar then you will actually fit the
model originally in our we would call
this just a train in cameras it's called
Fitz you'll do your evaluation on how
well your accuracy is doing and maybe
we'll do some plots to evaluate your
your accuracy in on several intervals
and then you'll protect either your
classes or a probability we have a cheat
sheet and I have if you search for Karis
cheat sheet at our studio finally but
there's the link as well and I think I
think it's time for a quick demo so yeah
that works alright so first of all you
are actually looking at an instance of a
studious server running on a virtual
machine in Google Cloud ml so standard
osteo server and the backend McCullough
I spent some time on on Monday to just
install or pro points you NVIDIA GPU
processes onto this machine so we have
GPU available and I am going to run some
code just so you can see how how the
integration works and just to make sure
that there's no jiggery-pokery limit
just restart my session one clean slate
all right so let me set the scene I have
a bit of code iam that takes some time
series data and it and the data was
originates from 15 people wearing a
chest mounted accelerometer and this
accelerometer measures acceleration XY
and z direction and they would then told
to do different activities walking and
running and sitting going up and down
stairs etc but the original task which
you can then make you can find the data
on the UCI david machine learning
website the original task was to predict
what activities is person doing we've
slightly flipped it in this example and
i'm saying i know that this person is
walking from the trace from the
accelerometer can i determine which
person is wearing the device small set
it's only 15 people so i don't think i'm
not claiming of this will work if you
have a million people right this
probably won't work but in this case of
toy example i think it's quite nice i'm
not going to run through the code right
here or my chemical step through the
code i'm going to just run it in one in
one once consecutive session and i want
you to observe just two things one is
there will be some red text that just
floats up momentarily and if you look
very carefully it's tend to flow
communicating back to the our session
saying i'm running on a GPU you may just
see that flashing past and then once the
training starts we have interactive
visualization in the our studio ide so
for every epoch so every full iteration
through all of the data it will update a
plot in the ide that gives you
instantaneous feedback on what's
happening so let's see if this works
gaudí starting there's the tensorflow
messages saying is I'm running on GPU
I'm not starting to train and there we
have the interactive plot flashing up I
think it's time to be about once every
second or so it will update and I can
look at this plot very briefly the soft
plot shows me my loss and the bottom
plot shows me my accuracy blue is my
training accuracy and greens my
validation accuracy so this is a nicely
behaved model where there's no big
discrepancy between validation and
training so this is this is nicely
behaved model okay so fine I switch back
into the slide I can just briefly give
you a bit more flavor on what's
happening so if you want to actually
write some more code I just want to give
some pointers about things you should be
careful about the first is that we have
there's this funny and operator here I'm
not even sure what to call it
it's it's a rule it's a reverse wife
right see that looks like a creature
pipe those of you familiar with him
greater or deeply our but it points the
other way and what this operator does it
gives you a way to mimic some of æneas
assignments of objects in our so this is
something you can do in Python very
easily you can say X comma y equals 1
comma 2 and that Y is sine x and y
simultaneously this operator allows me
to to simultaneously sine X train white
train X test Y tests which are embedded
objects in this data set M lists objects
ok so that's the first thing you should
just just take the note of that the
second important thing is array reshape
if this is important in the context of
Python versus R so you all pretty much
everybody said I'm going I use I so you
will know that an are vectors of Euro
matrices are
Hollander right column first but in most
other programming languages including
Python the arrays are row primary so you
have to use array reshape to get your
data in the format that tensorflow
understands do not try and use the demo
functional or that will not work
okay so just top pro tip just use array
we shape then the next line I have here
that's interesting is dividing X range
by 255
I'm just rescaling all my values in the
range 0 to 1 it's very important in in
tensorflow and Chara's to have your
input values scale to the same value and
you have to do it scale for the same
range and that range should be minus 1
to plus 1 or 0 to 1 if you don't do that
you you may get numerical convergence
problems so that's something that's in
most are packages that that algorithm
will take care for you and carrots you
have to do a little bit more work
yourself and then there are two
functions to categorical and some other
functions that that helps you convert
your your your factor levels to in
machine and their computer science world
is called one heart encoding in
statistics we call it dummy encoding so
you have to use this to categorical
function to make that work
ok and that's that then I'm defining a
model model in this case I have just
four layers a dropout layer dense layer
and so on I'm not going to explain that
right now you can find that in any
[ __ ] tutorial but that's fairly simple
to do again just notice the the pipe
function so here we have an art is very
very natural way to code in R then you
have to compile simple step one thing to
be careful about here do you not assign
the value back to your model right so if
you're inches in the technical detail is
this this is because this carrot an
object is in our 6 class so it's doing
modification by reference if you if you
accidentally reassign the value of this
step you'll get some very strange
results approach up don't do that okay
and then one don't we ready to train the
function is called fits we gain to
assign that objects you know the
resultant object called history which
means that I can plot that and I can
inspect that and if he simply called
plots on that history object you get a
nice juicy plot object with the same
information that I showed you earlier in
the dynamic plot okay that brief very
very quick overview of how chaos works
let me introduce you to one of the other
packages remember the table our heart
earlier on the right hand side we have
some supporting tools TF runs shorts or
aviation for tensorflow runs is I think
a fantastic way to manage your your
experiments and each experiment is a run
and really the only thing you need to
remember is that there's a function
called training run which is kind of
similar to source in R so in R you would
say source and runs the pantai script if
you do training one it will source the
entire script and file but it will do
some bookkeeping for you it will
remember or every run little what the
hyper parameters you were that you used
what was the exact code it will put that
into a small local version control so
you can go back and compare and it also
captures all your your outputs your
validation accuracy your training
accuracy and so on so you can easily
inspect after the fact what what's
happened by just querying it a dataframe
with that information so top top cone
used TF runs I'm actually at this point
I can just give a very quick demo of of
TF runs in practice the polished I run
through earlier is called walking
experiments and I'm going to run just
this one line of code training one
walking experiments and that's that is
going to solve that function
and they just make sure I have all the
correct libraries packages installed
okay now observe what's happening here
it's running through the same code you
will still get your interactive training
set happening this is exactly what you
saw earlier but once that is done with
some luck it will pop up a window that
shows me a summary of what what is in
this run and there we go so this is a
browser window that popped up that has
my plots it has all mine my metrics and
my model specification etc and this is
something I can query later back to my
house and then they'll give us a demo of
it later
great thanks so so far we've covered how
to really build a model and experiment
maybe on a local machine but how do you
really scale and deploy
so we're going to talk about the two
components of cloud ml engine the
training and serving piece and dive a
little bit into the code so first of all
cloud ml engine again is a managed
machine machine learning service we are
we're essentially also giving you
on-demand access to GPUs Andre mentioned
me and him work together the last few
days to actually install the NVIDIA P
100 GPU RTP use are also in beta so now
directly from your our console you'll be
able to access GPUs through this
interface when we talk about training
what does that really mean what we're
doing is we have a cloud ml underscore
train function that's really taking all
the our code uploading it into our
cluster servers installing all the
dependencies and now using using the
cloud for massive scale there andre also
talked about TF runs to really create a
systematic approach around experimenting
and really that concept around champion
versus challenger models and keep track
of all those and that's traditionally
using grid search techniques another
value of Cloud ml engine is we actually
have hyper parameter tuning using
Bayesian optimization that does it
automatically for you with an input file
where you give it some guidelines on
what evaluation metric you want to
maximize or minimize so you can see it's
fairly simple you package every
into a jar file now on the other side of
it really is around how do you deploy
these models again a few simple sdk
functions exporting the saved model the
one the one great thing about tensorflow
models also they are language and
platform agnostic they're binary files
that can be consumed by any type of
libraries and convert it into rest api
s-- so in this case we're gonna use the
deploy function to really publish or
register this model into a cloud
registry and now a number of developers
and analysts can now consume it as a
rest api call whether that be through
our in this case we use the predict
function but it could be a Python
developer a java application a mobile
application that all consume the same
model with the appropriate input input
provided and the response provided in a
in the appropriate format so we're gonna
now jump into an actual demo around
cloud machine learning engine how that
looks like and really opened up the
Google cloud platform console around
monitoring those scalable machine
learning training jobs and what may be a
portfolio of models are look like manage
in a central location
thanks mihail so okay I'm back in my
studio server session on on the VM as we
discussed earlier but as Michael
suggests search the point of cloud ml as
a service is that I can send my models
over to the to card ml for for training
or for hyper parameter tuning and we
have a package called wait for it cloud
ml that gives you a really great
integration to do exactly that so I'm
going to step you through some of the
functions to do that let me just make
sure I am in the right place so I'm and
folded cloud ml the configuration of
this package is actually straightforward
once you've installed caramel from cran
library card ml and then there's a
function G cloud underscore install this
will install your cloud ml STK on the
machine working with it will then once
the installation is done it will step
you through in rack
session where you have authenticates in
your browser to your cloud ml session
where you can just you can specify which
workspace I'm using etcetera so you can
cache your credentials on on any machine
that you're using so I did that last
night I didn't have to do that again so
I can simply proceed to training my
model so sitting while working directory
I'm loading the cloud ml package and now
car demo train and as you can see there
this is actually familiar because you've
already seen TF runs earlier where the
concept is that you not stepping through
your code directly you submitting your
script file got a contains your model 2d
runs in this case you submitting that
same file or a similar file to the cloud
email service the only thing that's
different now is that I'm specifying in
this case user I'm going to use a
standard GPU but you cannot use bigger
machines and I'm specifying that I have
a configuration in a Yama file called
tuning dot yml so let's to have a very
quick look at what walking cloud and all
that all looks like and what that Yama
file looks like so walking card MLR is
pretty much very similar to the file I
had earlier I have my file definitions
and then I have some layers so I have an
evolution layer and a maximum pulling
layer and drop out layer and so on but
at the top of this script I have I've
set up an optical flags and basically
I'm saying create a ref on op tech
called convolution one filters and give
it the value 16 and it'll look just a
little bit of lower down in my actual
script I can I can find that there we go
a convolution one flags dollar
convolution one filters so when the code
gets to this point it will look up the
value of that flag so it's very simple
I've set up a list of some values and
I'm just now referring to those values
in
so so far so so what right if I just run
the script as is it will take that value
of the flag and just use it but if I use
cloud ml underscore train with this
tuning at Yama file then some magic
happens
this Yama file is not particularly
difficult to decipher I have some some
proper parameters but information that's
up and I'm telling it you run for 25
trials so run 25 models run 3 of those
models in parallel but then I have my
parameter called con 1 folders which is
exactly the same flag of just looked at
I'd say that discrete value and do a
grid search of this value and will
increments that I specify 16 32 64 128
etc so basically you can see here that
I'm setting up a grudge that cloud ml
will search through so this is not quite
a random grid search because I'm cloud
email you would get the benefit of some
Bayesian optimization you will typically
see that over time the models the the
candidates get better but but that's
just what's going to happen is I'm going
to 125 trials on on the card ml service
and sampling some combination of these
flags every single time
now before I press the press or press
the Go button I want to show you if
you're not seeing this before the cloud
ml interface on Google so this is the
project that we held and I've been
working on you can see there's a history
we had some failed experiments they all
show up in red I can I can click through
into a log to get to try and understand
what went wrong in this case typically
it was because I misspelled some
variable though I didn't set something
up properly and then I started to have
some runs that were successful and last
you were successful so I think if I kick
off another job right now
should should just work with some luck
okay so let's try it and what I want you
to observe is that first of all thereís
going to be some feedback directly in
the console and then once the job starts
running I'll get feedback not in the
console but in the terminal window in
Ostia
so the terminal window this is I think
this is a result of a previous job let's
see what happens so the terminal window
gives me a view onto Linux that's
running on this machine okay so I'm
submitting will take just a few seconds
for Kluber mail to respond and then I
should start getting information and
instructions on what you go and do next
I mean while we're waiting there we go
it's responded saying with some
information but did you notice that it's
switched to the terminal window where
I'm now collecting results from the
cloud ml log so there we go
and these logs I can go in it's the same
log that I couldn't go inspect online
that the shows you the integration if I
just click back to the console it tells
me that this my job number ends in
double-o 8 I can go to this URL to
inspect what's happening on my job or in
the logs and I can run this command in R
to figure out to find out what's
happening so also notice that R itself
is not blocked so there's this job
running in card ml but I can do my
normal or code and I get an artist right
away so if I switch back to the Cardinal
console and just like refresh with some
luck I'll get that job number ending in
Wi 3 there we go and it said it's just
running for a minute and I can go and
view the logs and these are the same
logs I just showed you earlier so once
that wakes up
just takes a minute normally there we go
I can there we go it says now it's it's
cute and it's waiting to be provisioned
and this job from experience or no will
it's pretty much the same one I had this
the second job this will not continue to
run for the next hour and a half and the
beauty of this way of interacting with
Radamel is that this this is a service
it's not a virtual machine I had zero
installation on this machine I didn't
have to go and configure install
anything at all and the cloud email
package NAR will discover all my
dependencies I'm using deep line are I'm
using Kara's it will discover those
packages it will use packrats to get the
corresponding package and install those
on the cloud email service at the end of
the run that machine will come back with
results and the clock stops I'm not
getting charged and in anymore for that
machine running
okay that's cloud ml let's have a look
at if I actually copy this instruction
job status and until are okay tell me
what's happening there it I can I can
inspect what's happening there you go I
get back in our lists that tells me
information about when this job started
all the values he's going to choose and
also tells you away you are okay so
that's about as much as I want to do
about demo yeah I wanna show the cloud
machine learning model good point yes
yes sir can you switch over that yes the
one thing I wanted to talk about and
this is this is a topic I'm passionate
about again deploying those models for
consumption again the UI from from the
from the from the Google cloud platform
it's very simple but the idea is once
you register register those models
they're available in a central
repository for your organization to
manage and maintain I'm again you can
follow your own texana
here I've just published a few sample
models they might be relevant to certain
functions certain business lines I have
a couple here that maybe the digital
marketing marketing team has a model to
predict click-through rates we have a
computer vision Department that's trying
to recognize the image in there of a
product catalog some text classification
so all these models are now available
for REST API consumption I
I ran a loop to actually oh sorry to
actually see I ran a couple of calls to
the image classification model last
night and what this allows you to do
from a monitoring standpoint is maybe
take a look at the last 12 hours and it
really gives you a lot of information
around how many how often is model being
used by your applications by end-users
what is the predictions per second from
a performance standpoint also being able
to track latency and issues along with
the logging to have a nice way to see
you can see a lot of times we have a
pretty low latency but there's some
peaks during the night here when I ran
the loop or that that really could be a
problem and you can debug and make sure
these predictions are serving correctly
whether you need real-time predictions
or app batch I think we wanted to show
the the shiny examples as a front-end
and then we're gonna we're gonna wrap it
up
thanks McLeod okay so as Michelle
suggested we wanted to ploy this and he
said earlier you can deploy these models
as as api's in the service you can do
the same thing you can deploy tensorflow
models as an api in asti to connect
which is a NOS to de product that gives
you a publication platform to publish
your shiny apps or martin reports etc
and i want to show you one example of
that in in asti you connect live this is
a small toy example I wrote it uses a
pre trained Karis model so I didn't do
any training myself I used a publicly
available model that is fairly
sophisticated not it's number of years
old that you can get better models
these days and what it does is I can
tell it to upload a small image perhaps
of my dog
then once the image is uploaded it will
try and tell me what's there if thinks
my dog is a Malamute or collie maybe an
eskimo dog let's tell it to give me more
categories ten categories it definitely
thinks it's some kind of dog it's none
of those it's actually finished lapin
but it's if you know what a Malamute
looks like it's pretty good guess the
code itself is very simple it's only
about 1550 lines of code in total and
the key element of that code is in this
line here the application resonate 50 is
a built-in function in Charis Charis
comes with some pre trained models
including resonates and an inception and
exception and mobile net and all i did
was to say use that model and just score
on on my own image there's my scoring
function the predict image basically
it's just model then predict and then i
decode the predictions that plot
prediction that's that's the bar charts
and that's it that that's the entire
application if i if i upload a second
image maybe of my cart let's see what it
thinks well its thinks it's some kind of
cards like a car to a Gyptian cache i
think this is just a tabby cat really
alright so this is a little toy example
just to illustrate that you can use ten
to flow in your shiny app and actually
in this case I'm just using CPU in the
background I don't even have a GPU to
serve the scoring function so you might
get away with with not having a very
sophisticated machine I see some lost
that's probably because it thinks well
maybe it's a bucket or a plastic bag
go of go figure the perils of deep
learning don't assume that these things
are intelligent they not right they will
they will tell you what based on what
your training data said was just just to
close out I think it really takeaway you
as our community now has have a set of
libraries both to access tensorflow
Kerris scale and deploy using google
cloud i'm really in deep learning as as
a new toolkit in your in your chest
really allows you to open up new
applications tackle new domains and
challenging business problems and what
we're most excited again is what you
bring to the broader ml community with
applied math the statistical background
to really learn to teach the broader
community how to build ml models more
effectively a couple of things I know
our studio has a booth in Moscow and
West on level 2 we have a couple of
folks there you can stop by the Charis
cheat sheet is available we're also
excited to announce a new Kaggle
competition this is in partnership with
Google cloud and our studio so give it a
shot that'll be published very soon
where you can try out different
techniques including tensorflow
we mentioned our studio server Pro is a
one-click deployment that is available
on Google cloud platforms marketplace
and a couple of books again deep
learning for our eyes is something that
I really found very useful in my journey
of learning now just a couple of
suggestions I think for those who maybe
want a little bit one a little bit more
exposure to the new domains around deep
learning there's a great computer vision
session around satellite imagery with
one of our customers andre touched upon
this which is which is a great question
from the art community around deep
learning versus support vector machines
versus XG boost there's a great session
around sakya learn extra boost where it
talks a little bit about the trade-offs
around deep learning as well as our
traditional statistical techniques
there's two encore sessions that I very
much recommend for for folks who want a
little bit of a deep dive into
tensorflow tensorflow deep learning and
convolutional neural nets without a PhD
that was packed a lot of people can get
in yesterday I'll definitely recommend
I'm seeing that and if you're interested
in the broader ml AI spectrum within
Google cloud early from zero to ml on
Google cloud platform
everything from REST API s that you can
access as an analyst or a developer all
the way to really deploying and coding
in tensorflow tential there so hopefully
you get a notification around surveys
for this please fill them out and
provide us great feedback and we're
lucky where we have a lunch upcoming so
anyone who wants to stay back and ask
those questions will be here for the
next 30 minutes thank you everyone
[Music]
you